we always love doing the unexpected with
Scott Lang Batman is arguably the
character that is the most
underestimated Ant-Man became the key to
saving the universe in Avengers end game
so carrying that tradition we thought
well let's use this film to kick off
phase five
been almost a decade now that I've been
playing this part I've loved it and I
feel protective of Scott Lang and
Ant-Man it's really nice coming back I
still kind of can't believe that I'm
sitting there and it's like wow there's
Michelle Pfeiffer and there's Michael
Douglas I just saved eight bucks God I
admire you it's really nice not to get
used to working with Legends
[Music]
sending a signal down to the quantum
Realm
secret Universe beneath ours Janet has
been very quiet about her time in the
quantum realm maybe would have made
different choices there's someone I
never told you about
it isn't what you think Kang the
Conqueror is terrifying and if there
ever was a maniac loose in the quantum
realm it's him
playing Kang the Conqueror is such a
gift your reality everything you're
holding on to I know how it is this is
the beginning and he cannot be contained
something like this which is so
transportive and visually striking
people should really see it in movie
theaters
wanted to be as big and as visceral and
consuming as possible audiences are
going to watch this and go I can't
believe this is happening it's going to
be Bonkers it's like we're camping we've
never been camping but we've always
talked about it